epinephrine which is also adrenaline
those are the same thing is literally
manufactured from the molecule dopamine
if you look at the biochemical Cascade
it is dopamine is converted into
adrenaline which is the basis of all
energy all neural energy and so
including thinking and so if one is not
in a place of being able to set their
goal on a particular lofty goal a
graduate degree a book Etc yet the way
one gets to that is by completing things
in their immediate environment from
start to finish and closing the
dopaminergic loop those are at least
micro narratives
right so they're not integrated across a
long span of time but they're not
nothing and so one of the things well I
did write about this in my first book
particularly about putting your life
putting your house in perfect order it's
like well if you if you're lost
one of the things you can do is look
around and see what direction you could
take locally is fix something
[Music]
foreign
foreign
I'm pleased today to have with me Dr
Andrew d huberman
he's a neuroscientist and tenured
associate professor in the department of
neurobiology at the Stanford University
School of Medicine
Dr huberman and his lab have made
contributions to the brain development
brain plasticity and neural regeneration
and repair fields
his work and his lab's work focuses on
the visual system elucidating the nature
of neural mechanisms controlling light
mediated activation of the Circadian and
autonomic arousal centers in the brain
and mediating conscious Vision or sight
his lab investigates how the brain works
how it changes through experience it's a
field known as plasticity and how it
repairs itself
he and his colleagues have worked to
discover strategies for halting and
reversing vision loss in blinding
diseases and understanding how visual
perceptions and autonomic arousal states
are integrated to impact behavioral
responses his lab employs a large range
of state-of-the-art investigative tools
virtual reality gene therapy anatomy
electrophysiology and imaging and
behavioral analysis
in January 2021 Dr huberman launched the
huberman Lab podcast concentrating on
neuroscience and other scientific topics
it's done phenomenally well for a
detailed scientific podcast attracting
1.5 million subscribers
it's very good to see you today Dr
huberman and thank you for agreeing to
talk with me I'm delighted to be here uh
your first book 12 rules for life sits
prominently on our bookshelf in our
living room and we've all read it and
learned a tremendous amount from you
over the years and certainly feel a
kinship because of the shared
relationship between University
professorship and public education as
well
right right yeah well we've got lots in
common I'm particularly interested in
the neurological work that you've done
on both anxiety and exploration although
there's plenty of topics to talk about
today and plenty of overlapping
interests but it's been a while since
I've reviewed the Neuroscience
literature pertaining to both anxiety
and exploration and so I maybe we could
start by you laying out what you've
discovered and how you're thinking about
what you think anxiety signifies how
it's related to exploratory Behavior
which I think you described as something
approximating courageous approach
although you were talking about mice in
that particular paper and uh what you
think what you're thinking about with
regards to the neural basis of these
different uh behavioral responses
behavioral and emotional responses sure
I'd be happy to and she mentioned that
these days my laboratory mainly focuses
on humans we still do some mouse work
but we
um in partnership with people in
Psychiatry we're doing essentially
equivalent experiments in humans so I'd
be happy to elaborate there
you know uh many people perhaps but not
everyone have heard of the autonomic
nervous system which simply means
automatic it's a bit of a misnomer
because
um without going too much into the
history of that if you look back to the
the origins of medicine in the time of
Galen and so forth
um when they were first you know
dissecting cadavers and whatnot there
was this idea
of a nurse of a nervous system or a
portion of the nervous system eventually
came to be that could control so-called
vegetative functions meaning that rate
of digestion and the Really uh what
neuroscientists typically think of as
boring stuff but it's anything but
boring it's the stuff that keeps you
from urinating while you're asleep if uh
unless you're a very young child right
and it's the stuff that keeps your
digestion going as you uh command your
attention to other things the autonomic
nervous it's all the things it's all the
things that are too complex for us to
Think Through that's right and they are
as you point out immensely complex and
you know nowadays with all this interest
in the microbiome and things of that
sort I mean these are
um tremendously complicated operations
that are happening generally below our
conscious awareness and that are indeed
vegetative they can be controlled by
emotion you know we were all familiar
with the the idea that when we are
emotionally distraught that our
digestion can be different or uh Etc but
typically we can't control for instance
in a conscious way the rate of our
digestive or the speed of our heartbeat
in any kind of direct way we can have a
particular pattern of thought to control
those but in general those functions
were thought to be vegetative and
outside of our conscious control and the
name autonomic nervous system sort of
swallowed and overtook the vegetative
part so it includes that but also
um three main aspects of body to brain
signaling and those three aspects are
heart rate could be quickening or
slowing of heart rate we we are and we
can be very aware of that some of us
more than others gut
and the especially the chemical
composition and the extent to which our
gut is empty or full so stump so heart
stomach and then rate of breathing and
sort of depth of breathing meaning how
much air we have available to us and I
think the three main ways to think about
the way that the brain and body
communicate is that they it's either
going to be mechanical or chemical let's
use the gut as an example your stomach
can feel acidic
or it can feel nice and warm and fuzzy
whatever that is in a chemical sense
your heart rate can feel like it's going
at a rate that's appropriate for your
circumstances you know if you're running
it could be quick and if you're sitting
in a chair quietly at the doctor's
office waiting to be called back there
and all of a sudden your heart starts
racing then you would think well that's
appropriate for that situation but it's
uncomfortable right it's out of sync
with what you are doing which is sitting
so there's mechanical information and
then there's chemical information and
with respect to your lungs you know you
can feel like you're out of air or you
have plenty of air you can feel like
your your breathing is labored or it's
easy or in the chemical sense that the
uh the air that you're breathing your
lungs are burning or it feels easy to
breathe so basically there's chemical
and mechanical signaling from the body
to the brain and the Brain interprets
all of that and we put all of that Under
the Umbrella of the so-called autonomic
nervous system
and the autonomic nervous system can
really be best thought of along a
Continuum and here I'll avoid
complicated nomenclature but I'll throw
it out there for the aficionados some
people have probably heard of the
parasympathetic and the sympathetic that
naming is a little bit misleading again
what we can really think about the
autonomic nervous system as is a
Continuum or more like a seesaw of at
one end is alertness
and at the other end is calmness right
uh that is translated to the so-called
sympathetic and parasympathetic nervous
system but I'll call it the alertness
and calmness system just for sake of
simplicity so it's sort of like a seesaw
and it has different neural circuits and
basically whether or not you feel very
alert or panicked or alert but calm or a
little bit of anxiety that's going to
depend on the balance between this
alertness system and the calmness system
if you're having a full-blown panic
attack then the alertness system is you
know it's as if the Seesaw is tilted all
that way if you have
um if you're deeply asleep well then the
calmness system is really tilted down
you could say that's a portion of the
Seesaw this is all kind of obvious and
it dates back you know 100 years or so
which isn't that long in the history of
science but we've known this sort of
thing for a while okay what's
interesting and I think more relevant
nowadays is to think about one's own
interpretation of those signals and how
that relates to anxiety and as you
pointed out exploration and then to
think about where the nodes of control
are in this seesaw um model that that
I'm putting forward the Seesaw has to
include what I would call a hinge a
location in the middle in which you can
voluntarily adjust the Seesaw to either
be more tilted toward alert or more
tilted towards asleep and for many
people they find that their overall
level of autonomic arousal is either
inappropriate or inadequate for the
demands of their life inappropriate
meaning their heart is racing they feel
more jittery more as if movement would
be the default and worry would be the
default and pre and anticipation is the
default then is appropriate for their
circumstances waking up in the morning
and feeling stressed for instance
immediately without any immediate cause
or maybe stress about real life events
for other people they feel more
exhausted than they would like they're
having a hard time leaning into the
pressures of daily life both of those
even though they have sort of polarized
phenotypes they look very different in
one case over energized in one case
under energized both originate within
the autonomic nervous system and we can
reliably say from work done in animals
and humans that that is not the
consequence of
the alertness system or the calmness
system being disrupted but rather that
that hinge in the middle is dysregulated
and we now know what that hinge is and
this is based on work done by colleagues
of mine at Stanford in particular guy
named David Spiegel who's our associate
chair of Psychiatry he's done a lot of
work and is actually his father did a
lot of work in the application of
clinical hypnosis not stage hypnosis but
clinical hypnosis for the treatment of
various things but his work and some
work in our laboratory now has shown
that there's an area of the brain that
you are familiar with Dr Peterson which
is the the prefrontal cortex and in
particular the left dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex if you really want to
get down in the Weeds about it that has
direct communication with two brain
areas that are absolutely critical for
this issue of whether or not you feel
right for your circumstances whether or
not you translate that into a curiosity
and exploration or whether or not you
translate it into this thing that we
call anxiety
and those two areas are called the
anterior cingulate cortex again I
apologize for all the names but the
anterior cingulate cortex and the insula
and I think if I were to make a
prediction about what the buzzword is
going to be in popular Neuroscience in
the next five years it's not the
amygdala it's not the prefrontal cortex
it's the insula the insula has a couple
of different regions but one of its
primary regions the front end the
anterior insula is responsible for
interpreting all those bodily signals it
essentially is a funnel for all those
signals about breath rate heart rate
conditions of the gut
um whether or not your body feels ready
to move or exhausted Etc and that all
funnels into the insula and then also
coming into the insula as information
from classical areas like the amygdala
which are involved in threat detection
and fear and also emotion and memory so
the insula is really this incredible Hub
of information about somatic signals
about bodily signals and then the
prefrontal cortex the dorsolateral
cortex in particular is in communication
with the insula and literally makes a so
so let me ask you about that so so does
that mean that so that the body in some
senses reporting to conscious awareness
now it reports unconsciously in all
sorts of ways too so it might report to
the hypothalamus which is a very low
level brain control area by the way for
those of you who are listening it might
report to the hypothalamus primarily
unconsciously but do you think it's the
insula that's reporting on the nature of
bodily states to the prefrontal cortex
in a manner that allows us to be
consciously aware of our body States
that's exactly that part of that
integration system that's exactly right
you're exactly right the insula sits as
a as a different sort of station in that
it's reporting to the conscious areas of
the brain
to the prefrontal cortex right so we can
take them into we can take our own
physiological State into account then
when we're envisioning plans because
part of what the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex does is
allow us to Envision different possible
Futures and those are plans and you're
not going to make a plan to run two or
three blocks to get to the corner store
if you're so exhausted you can't get out
of bed and you need a reporting
mechanism that tells you what physical
state you're in so that you can
predicate your plans on that you think
the insulin at least in part is
responsible for formulating those those
representations or for reporting those
representations that is exactly right in
fact the animal data and the human data
both lesion data and reversible
inactivation data support that in human
so you have that exactly right and as
you mentioned the the prefrontal cortex
you know it gets sort of thrown out
there for everything I think you know
nowadays people have probably heard of
the prefrontal cortex and people hear
about executive function which of course
is true but if we were to really dial
back and say what is the prefrontal
cortex in the position to do it's a
flexible rule setting
structure how do we know that yet I'm
sure you are probably more familiar than
I am with the the classic Stroop task
you know you give somebody a bunch of
cards with different um words on them
and those words are written in different
colors and you tell the person
um okay just read the words to me ignore
the color that they're written and just
read them and so they're saying they're
cat dog Shelf book Professor student Etc
then you quickly change the rules and
you say you know what
um just tell me the color that the words
are written in but ignore what the words
say and people will do that but there's
a portion of time in which they have
they slow down a bit it's actually hard
because you've done a rule switch much
of life as you know and again this is
more your domain than mine is about
applying different rules in different
contexts now what we know is that the
insula and the prefrontal cortex are
both intimately involved in this
conversation that establishes which
rules are appropriate for a given
situation so for instance
um if somebody were to say something
that quote unquote triggers me okay I'll
use myself as the example right maybe
somebody will tweet something and I'll
think ah you know and I immediately want
to respond in a way that I know I can
kind of like flip them on their back
immediately but then I think ah you know
maybe I want to refrain from that for a
number of any number of different rules
or reasons right well then I have to I'm
starting to apply different rules I'm
starting to think about the context
that's outside of the autonomic response
because in a strict very animalistic way
in other words in the absence of an
insula in a prefrontal cortex
conversation really the only thing an
animal or human needs to do is just
respond to their arousal in you know
it's either uh you can either Retreat
you can stay put or you can fight right
that's really the only three uh three
major those are very fast responses
generally so so so so let me ask you
about the role of the pre-federal cortex
in what you described as rule a
switching because I would I would like
to know what you think about whether or
not the prefrontal cortex is actually
let's say switching rules or if it if
what it's doing is switching context
sensitive behavioral patterns that when
we talk about we describe as rules
[Music]
the government continues to spend
borrowed money inflation continues to
swell dragging down our economy and the
stock market has entered bear territory
so what's your plan are your assets
Diversified I'm Phillip Patrick precious
metal specialist for the Birch gold
group for nearly 20 years we've helped
Americans diversify into gold and we can
help you too did you know you can own
physical gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account we can help you
transfer an IRA or 401K tied to stocks
into an IRA in Gold if you're skeptical
about the trajectory of the economy in
the US dollar then text Jordan to 989898
Birch gold group will send you a free
info kit on securing your savings with
gold with thousands of satisfied
customers five star reviews and an
A-Plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau we take Precious Metals seriously
text Jordan to 989898 for your free info
kit
it's a it's a it is the critical
question that you're asking the
prefrontal cortex in particular the left
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex is in an
incredibly unique position to not only
establish different rules depending on
context and the way it does that is by
accessing memory so the hippocampus has
access to frontal cortex and vice versa
it's almost always a reciprocal
conversation so it can pull memory
thinking oh you know the last time I
responded like that didn't get me the
result I wanted or the last time I
responded in this other way I got the
result I wanted again regardless of
situation the other thing that the pre
left or lateral prefrontal cortex is
exquisitely positioned to do and this is
um beautiful work of a colleague of Mine
by the name of Nolan Williams also in
Psychiatry is because of its connections
to some structures that then feed into
the vagus nerve it actually can slow the
heart rate down
so in other words let's say someone says
something and your immediate impulse is
to fight or uh to respond in a kind of
knee-jerk way if you halt right I guess
what the meditators and the mindfulness
folks was called The Gap or if you can
access some memory and think ah and and
you might be thinking you know actually
there's a much better way to place the
dart if I just kind of lean back a
little bit or it could be you know
silence might be the best response right
um or it could be that you're going to
carefully access some data from your
hippocampus to respond in a way that is
most effective uh for instance here I'm
talking about confrontation but it could
be any situation the left door cilateral
prefrontal cortex does two things as it
acquires a new rule set or starts to
access information about a new or
possible rule set it also sends a
parallel signal to slow the heart down
through the vagus nerve and that is I
think one of the more important and
fascinating discoveries in the last five
years those aren't data from my
laboratory I wish they were but
it's very clear that when we start
accessing alternate rule sets there's a
signal that quiets the body in some ways
and position is that partly how you calm
yourself down that's right it is how you
calm yourself down and again you have
the clinical background not I but um I
I'll confess I've I've been in therapy
enough to know that occasionally you
know one feels as if you're accessing
some piece of info as the patient side I
can only report from the patient side
you know accessing some what feels like
important piece of information you're
pulling on a thread of some sort but
then the therapist will say something
and it it literally gives you that
alternate View and this notion of
looking at things through a different
perspective we often think about that as
a switch in our cognitive frame in our
in our thinking but also we now know
there's this parallel signal that's sent
to the body in which in order to access
these alternate rule sets new ways of
looking at things there's a calming
signal literally sent to the body as
well and I find this conversation
fascinating because normally we just
think about anxiety and exploration and
Rule setting and Rule responses or
responses to rules Etc as a kind of the
body send signals and the brain does all
this what neuroscientists have always
talked about is top down processing
right just sort of suppress the
hypothalamus control the limbic system
right and that's true to some extent but
there's also it's clear there are
signals being sent to the body in
parallel and rather than look at the
signals more like conducting than
suppressing exactly like conducting like
an Orchestra orchestrator conductor
exactly and there's a very interesting
phenomenon that takes place in people
that have chronic anxiety or for people
who essentially stop accessing alternate
rules and responses to these signals and
this is I think what is showing up in
chronic anxiety certainly in certain
forms of depression and when people
enter states of rage and dysregulation
is that normally we know based on
neuroimaging that the prefrontal cortex
is essentially leading the response of
the of this anterior cingulate cortex in
the insula so information is coming up
from the body into the insula and then
being fed to the prefrontal cortex but
then the prefrontal cortex is actually
in a position to lead responses and it
essentially is acting like the coach of
a team and the team is all these
structures like the ACC and the interior
Cingular cortex and the insula the heart
rate and so forth what happens in
individuals who have chronic anxiety or
damage to the prefrontal cortex or
dysregulation of these circuitries is
that that order actually reverses the
insula nacc start leading and directing
the response of the prefrontal cortex
and I think you know we see this in I'm
sure you've seen this clinically in
individuals and um while this isn't
necessarily a discussion about Society
at large I mean we see this in
dysregulated arguments and dysregulated
combat where people is essentially
losing themselves and they default to
one what appears to be very primitive
rule set and it may or may not be the
appropriate one but as you and I of
course have the Good Fortune of knowing
a number of people who've worked in
Special Operations and things like that
and you talk to any of those individuals
and they know from experience and from
training that their ability to
access multiple rule sets and options in
the moments of extreme autonomic arousal
is actually where their power lies right
it's the or or a combat fighter or let's
just take ordin debate right something
that you're far more versed in than I am
right although I guess every academic
has to deal with a bit of that coming up
the thesis defense Etc in a really good
debate you can't allow the autonomic
response to overtake you
or you lose access to an enormous
database that resides in your one's
hippocampus and you essentially one then
defaults to the the bodily state right
and this is what we see when we see
people become dysregulated in Rage Etc
so if we were to zoom out and then ask
you know where is the line between
exploration and anxiety I think that we
can check off a few boxes for sure first
of all that autonomic arousal this this
tendency to be more alert or more in
action than in non-action is a very
healthy response I mean at the moment
adrenaline is released from the adrenals
and and as you know there's a parallel
signal in the brain you know you get
adrenaline released from the adrenals if
you get in a cold shower or somebody
says something triggering or you are
afraid of heights or something but the
brain has its own kind of adrenaline
system which is this structure in the
back of the brain called Locus ceruleus
and it basically has a it essentially
sprinklers the entire brain with
noradrenaline and adrenaline it's a very
interesting system it is lacks
specificity it basically wakes up the
whole brain if you were if I were to put
a little
um if I were to label the connections of
the locus cerules it's basically
connected to everything it just kind of
sprinkles a caffeine-like substance on
the entire brain wakes you up the
adrenals in the body wake up the body so
two parallel systems wake us up
is that associated with The orienting
Reflex
yes if you Orient is the locus
corrillius wake up the brain absolutely
yeah so it's a key component of the
so-called reticular activating system to
get our activating system yeah and and
incidentally I I should mention this um
because
I was going to come to this later but I
think it's relevant now if somebody has
a lesion in their dorsalateral
prefrontal cortex or if you transiently
inactivate it with a technology a
non-invasive technology like
transcranial magnetic stimulation they
can now just put a magnet on outside the
skull and quiet that area of the brain
transiently in animals or humans what
you find is that that person or human
becomes incredibly accurate at any motor
task so for instance if I
um were to give you a shooter game where
you're supposed to shoot targets and I
and you're shooting targets you'll have
some some hits and some misses like
anybody
um if I inactivate your dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex your accuracy goes
through the roof it's near 100 but the
one thing you can't do is decide whether
or not you're shooting an enemy or a uh
or a friend so you can no longer
establish rules you just become very
good at execution of the motor Behavior
similarly in an animal or person without
a dorsalateral prefrontal cord you see a
trade-off there right between between
specificity and and flexibility that's
right and so and so we see this theme
over and over again where as a purely
you know sensory motor response machine
the prefrontal cortex isn't even
necessary in fact if you get rid of it
entirely people become like machines if
I click over here somebody has no
prefrontal cortex basically everything
becomes a stimulus a puppy everything's
a stimulus you know I used to have a
bulldog when he was a puppy you had to
worry about leaving cords out and
everything was went into his mouth by
time he was you know a year old in part
because he was a bulldog you just kind
of lay there like you could put a toy in
front of him and he wasn't into playing
and just leave it alone a baby
everything's a stimulus many adults
become infant like in their responses
right when anxiety is high in fact I
have a friend who's a psychologist tell
me if you agree with this statement or
not that anxiety makes children of us
all I don't know if that's true or not
but
um certainly has been my experience that
when feeling anxious I don't struggle
with chronic anxiety but I certainly
feel like have felt anxiety well it
simplifies us I mean all these
underlying emotions and motivational
States these primordial instincts are
simplification mechanisms and so if
we're unable to compute a complex and
sophisticated pathway forward that takes
multiple variables into account
simultaneously we can't just do nothing
we're going to default to a more
primordial and direct State and then you
might say the whole panoply of emotions
and motivations lies there at the weight
for us to grip our Behavior Behavior if
we're what would you say if we're
Paralyzed by inability to choose between
multiple options and so we do to the
degree that we're simplified by an
emotion then we're reduced to something
more approximating in an infantile state
if you watch two-year-olds and
two-year-olds are particularly
interested in this regard they basically
just cycle through
innate motivational States it makes them
really interesting to be around because
when they're interested in something
they're 100 percent interested in it and
then when they're angry they're a
hundred percent angry and if they're
anxious they're 100 percent anxious and
they can and tired they just instantly
fall into a coma and they just cycle
through these with no overarching
centralized integration and it's partly
because they likely don't really
manifest any
integrating prefrontal cortical capacity
until they hit about three where they
can start to engage in joint play states
with other children right and then they
can exercise then they can they can
modulate their underlying emotions in
accordance with an abstract
representation or goal sometimes that's
jointly shared that's part of developing
sophistication it's also why the idea
that identity is subjectively defined is
absolutely Preposterous it's like it's
subjectively defined for two-year-olds
but it's not subjectively defined for
anyone who's sophisticated enough to
negotiate with someone else
and so tell me about tell me what you
think about this
um my understanding of the prefrontal
cortex is that over the course of
evolutionary time it grew out of the
frontal cortex and that out of the motor
cortex more specifically and so the best
way to think about what the prefrontal
cortex does in some sense is that it
generates potential abstract patterns of
action it generates them in abstraction
so that they can be assessed before
they're implemented and so it's like
it's generating potential future cells
that's exactly right you see that's okay
that's exactly right and and and I'm I'm
glad you stated it not not I because it
you say that far more clearly and
succinctly than I've heard it stated
before it's it's as if it's running
potent you know running plays uh I'm
using a sports analogy it's running
plays and thinking about potential
outcomes you know the I'm not a chess
player although you know Lex Friedman's
podcast and Lex Friedman are convincing
me that perhaps I should learn because
it's there's a lot of discussion about
Chess nowadays and there's a lot of
thinking as I understand about potential
outcomes you know how many moves can you
anticipate if if this then that it's
sort of if this then that right thinking
and if you think about its connectivity
it's in a beautiful position based on
its access to priors through the
hippocampus so memory it can take into
account current state bodily state it
can access information for instance
about do I have the energy do I have the
resources to undergo a particular
pattern of response and that's through
the insula and the ACC and then the
dorsalateral prefrontal cortex
in this way of also being able to
control the body of being able to calm
the body this is a very unique pathway
because typically we think of the heart
heart rate is going up if we're excited
or scared and heart rate going down if
we're calm but really the default of the
neural inputs to the heart and to the
breathing systems Etc are to be very
activated and then the brain provides a
suppressive or kind of a breaking on
that entire the vagus nerve right so
it's a default on system it's a default
on system in the vagus nerve which of
course is a massive nerve pathway again
it makes it sound like one little nerve
but it's this huge Super Highway of
connections between brain and body is is
classified in medical school as a
parasympathetic pathway meaning of the
calming system it kind of generically
speaking and indeed it is and so that
the prefrontal cortex we can think of as
remember in the the Seesaw analogy the
hinge the prefrontal cortex is more or
less like the screwdriver that tightens
that hinge essentially make sure that
that the Seesaw stays at a level at a
tilt that's appropriate for whatever it
is that you happen to be doing okay now
I presume
I personally imagine so to continue the
evolutionary analog so
um an animal that doesn't have a lot of
behavioral flexibility generally its
reproduction strategy is multiple copies
of itself maybe hundreds maybe thousands
and the reason for that is all the
variability in the animal's behavior is
genetically coded and so for it to adapt
to the transforming Horizon of the
future it has to produce multiple
variants of itself most of which die
with mosquitoes for example they produce
thousands of of eggs and if they all
lived would be knee-deep in mosquitoes
in like 10 years but they almost all of
them die because they're not matched to
the transformation that's coming down
the pipeline but with human beings what
we seem to have done is evolved a
mechanism for manufacturing artificial
cells in this game-like manner and so we
can put forward
optional selves in abstraction and then
kill them off when they're not necessary
without us dying and so the famous quote
I think it was Alfred North Whitehead
was that the purpose of thought was to
let our our thoughts die instead of us I
love that and it really makes us unique
yeah it's great it's absolutely great
and so and that it seems to me too you
tell me what you think about this is
that the
the
abstracted artificial cells
uh avatars in some sense that the
prefrontal cortex generates or that it
allows these underlying motivational and
emotional systems to generate because
they can generate simple avatars by
themselves I think when we describe
those we're describing we're telling
stories
when we describe one of these
alternative modes of action that's
precisely it it's the verbal description
of that is a story that's right you know
and you make a very important point
which is that the prefrontal cortex is a
rule-changing
um alternate self-accessing machine that
can also calm the body and and here I'm
um I'm making up a gesso story because
as I always say I wasn't consulted at
the design phase and so I don't know why
it's set up this way I just know that it
is set up this way
um one reason to suppress the somatic
response the bodily response is that
tends to be a unitary interpretation
meaning at this moment I feel alert but
calm so I feel good but I'm guessing
there's a lot of signals coming from the
body and in fact there are to my brain
but I tend to just say I feel pretty
good in fact I'm very delighted to be
here so I feel good or if I'm very tired
I feel tired those tend to be very kind
of
um binned responses and they're fairly
generic whereas your description of what
the prefrontal cortex does which is an
accurate one I should say of imagining
different selves and different outcomes
almost requires that we suppress how we
feel in our body in the moment you know
I guess we can look to some of our
podcasting um colleagues like the the
Jocko willings or the the David Goggins
you know who are
um either forcing themselves uh or are
somehow up at 4 30 in the morning and
train pushing through that what I call
limbic friction you know the limbic
system is saying I'm tired or I'm
anxious and you know going against that
so there's there's literally a there
there's a required suppression of the
bodily response in order to imagine how
we would feel when we complete this or
how terrible we would how much of that
how much of that so let's parse that
into two parts because you can imagine
there's an inhibitory component where
you're directly in competition with an
underlying urge so the top down story is
so for example if you're responding to
Something in an irritable way that's
been directed to you on Twitter there's
going to be a limbic rage response
that's associated with that which you
can then suppress but then
the the question there that's quite
complex I would say is something like to
what degree do you think you're directly
suppressing that with the prefrontal
cortex and to what degree do you think
you're spinning up an alternative self
that if embodied wouldn't require that
physiological response and so you're
switching to a new identity in which
that limbic response is no longer
um is no longer germane yeah and so the
reason that it disappears is not because
you directly suppress it in an
inhibitory manner but because you
replace what's necessary physiologically
given your new understanding of the
territory that you inhabit I think it's
some of both but I've never been able to
to really like wrestle that through yeah
I so I think um what you're getting to
is what we know is that the the
prefrontal cortex and its Associated
networks contain a a near infinite if
not infinite set of possibilities right
I mean of course it's it's um it's
bottlenecked by experience and it's
bottlenecked by one's imagination but
you know the number of different
possible cells that one could imagine is
near infinite if one were to spend time
on it whereas the number of different
bodily states that one can
have are actually very finite and if you
think about the autonomic nervous system
and the and in my laboratory we've
studied this typically in the context of
fear and confrontation that the simplest
way to put this in a kind of a um in a
kind of Pop Neuroscience way would be to
say you know we can either be back on
our heels meaning retreating
or we can be flat-footed sort of calm in
our stance or we can be forward Center
of mass we can be in sort of pursuit and
or competition there there really aren't
other motor responses for an animal
including humans right you can either
stay put right back up or go forward you
know and this is yeah well it's useful
for people to know that that's the basic
platform upon which emotions are erected
too is that emotions are like signals of
those of those action Tendencies and
they are very simple it's back up get
away stop or move forward and so
generally we associate positive emotion
with forward movement and that would be
positive emotion that's dopaminergically
mediated fundamentally right and then
the halting would be well it can be
calmness because there's nothing to do
but it can also be the paralysis that
fear induces and then panic and Retreat
are more they're sort of on the border
between anxiety and pain I suppose pain
responses yeah exactly right complicated
in yeah yeah so these three major
categories are I think Encompass most if
not all of the possible responses as you
said and probably form the the base set
for all emotions I mean my laboratory
studied this mainly in the context of
fear and confrontation and one of the
reasons we started to explore this was
the following you know we we've all
heard a fight or flight or rest and
digest right those correspond to the
alertness system and the and the
calmness system of the autonomic nervous
system in their kind of extreme forms
but what we observed in animals and then
now in human studies
we published about a year ago is that
when people are confronted with an
anxiety provoking scenario in our case
we do this with virtual reality because
we need to do it in the laboratory we
find that we find their pain Point
essentially and by pain point I don't
mean extreme fear I mean the thing that
can raise their autonomic arousal that
has them in a mode of considering
different options and trying to figure
out what is strategic and what they're
capable of in that moment could be
Heights could be confrontation with a
predator animal it varies by person do
people but everyone has their pain Point
even uh even Navy Seals that we've
brought to the laboratory or other
people from the Special Operations
Community they all each and everyone has
their pain Point what they do in
response to that pain point is really
what's interesting and what we found was
that the pause or freeze response
certainly was associated with autonomic
arousal with Stress and Anxiety we
measure this in the brain and body
but it was the lowest anxiety response
people always think of panic you know
just being paralyzed in panic that's
actually the lowest anxiety response
retreat was the next level up in terms
of levels of heart rate change and
levels of change within the insula of
all places we actually recorded from
Human insula through a partnership with
neurosurgeons
and then we found that there were subset
of individuals and animals in the
parallel animal work that would confront
a fear
not necessarily reflexively but after
some consideration they would lean into
the challenge essentially confront the
thing that was making them feel anxious
and it turned out that that response
surprisingly was associated with the
highest levels of autonomic arousal and
this game right so but that would be
that would be heart rate activation
particularly heart rate activation and
heart rate activation and a change in
what it's called the so-called gamma
wave activity in the insula we had
electrodes in the insulin what we found
was that people who were willing to lean
into that challenge yeah there the
insula took on essentially a a change in
its activity patterns this gamma pattern
the heart rate increased breathing
increased sweating increased so these
are all the marks of an anxiety attack
but here if you were to just look at the
behavior of the person or the animal
what you'd find is that they were
marching forward toward Their Fear this
is the you know and so then that's
voluntary exploration right so now you
do did an animal study with mice where
you show if I remember correctly that
the mice that were showing tail flicking
which was a prodroma to that exploratory
activity showed a particular form of
brain activity that if you replicated
with stimulation was more potently
reinforcing than sexual stimulation
right so here's where the the surprise
came that the additional surprise came
in we thought okay wow well there are
animals these mice will tail flick in
the in response to a threat which is
essentially saying come on let's go
let's fight whereas other animals would
Retreat and that tail flicking um
paralleled within the human studies with
people being confronted with for someone
who's scared of heights to go through a
virtual reality scenario of being up on
a high beam between buildings might not
sound like a big deal to the average
video gamer or to you and me but is it
absolutely terrifying experience for
those people but a subset of them will
just March out onto that platform where
we'll even Explore jumping off the
platform with the understanding that
it's not that it's virtual and get very
scared but they will do it and they also
show these changes in insole activity
and changes in heart rate and breathing
what was interesting to us was the mouse
data told us that if you stimulate the
brain area that was associated with all
of this it's an area of the midline
thalamus I don't get down into details
of structures too much but it was a very
mysterious area had not been explored
much before uh had this incredible name
of nucleus reunions why I don't know the
neuroanatomists name these things
peculiar ways as you know but if we were
to stimulate that brain area in mice we
could convert a terrified
non-confrontational Mouse into a mouse
that was willing to confront its fears
in a healthy and adaptive way it wasn't
being foolishly running into the jaws of
a predator it was being very strategic
in its confrontation
the the interesting thing was if we
introduced no fear stimulus no Heights
no Predator no nothing and we just
tickle this brain area
what we found is that animals and humans
love that feeling in fact they will work
for that feeling more than they will
work for other stimulation and in how do
okay so a bunch I've got a bunch of
questions about that so the first is how
do you think that's related to
hypothalamic dopaminergic release in
exploratory States and the psychomotor
stimulated effects of drugs like cocaine
and amphetamine and then second if you
put someone in a chronic state of
activating that brain area say you did
that by teaching them to approach their
fears rather than to run from them would
that produce epigenetic changes that
would transform them physiologically
okay so um both very important questions
um first of all
the dopamine system is absolutely
critical here in the animal studies we
identified because we could place
tracers in the brain and measure
connections that indeed this brain area
in the midline thalamus connects
directly to the major hubs of dopamine
released in the brain they have names
like nucleus accomplish okay et cetera
ventral tegmental area right so that was
great because it confirmed for us that
so it is tapping the primary approach
related positive reward system that's
right but it's a very it's a very major
nucleus that allows that to happen
particularly in the face of voluntary
approach to feared stimuli that's
exactly right and you know one thing
about the dopamine system that's so
important and also explains a lot of
pathology but also a lot of uh human
evolution is that we have basically one
major reward system which is the
dopaminergic system you know uh I
sometimes like the analogy that you know
nowadays you hear about cryptocurrency
or the dollar versus the Euro versus the
this versus that there's only one
currency in all of reality actually in
this dopamine whether or not it's the
dollar back to dopamine or it's eurobact
dopamine or Bitcoin back dopamine in the
end whether or not someone has a billion
dollars or two dollars is really that
that currency resides as something
that's transact transacted in the real
world but their notion of power and
potential is dopaminergic and so too the
potential for mates the potential for
food how much food you have you know how
much meat you have stored in the freezer
tells you a lot about your security and
well-being for you and your family right
and that's but and that is translated
into a dopaminergic internal
representation of how safe and secure
you are Etc
so this system of fear versus
confrontation Taps directly into the
dopaminergic system and there's a
beautiful set of studies that were done
in the 1960s uh published in the journal
science as you know one of the you know
one of the top journals to publish in
um again this is not work that that I uh
did but where they gave people human
beings the option to stimulate a number
of different brain areas just sitting in
the clinic and some brain areas would
evoke feelings of drunkenness feel
others would evoke feelings of of anger
others of sadness others of sexual
arousal and the area that these subjects
all prefer to stimulate the most in fact
they would just sit there and lever
press pretty much all day long was this
midline Thalamus area and the subjective
feeling that they reported I find this
interesting and would love your thoughts
on this is one of mild frustration
anticipation of something although they
didn't know what anticipate and it's
this idea I think that it's tapping into
the dopamine system and
the dopamine system the dopamine system
says something good is going to happen
that's right the key so something good
is going to happen something good is
going to happen and it's it's it's an
it's an appetitive state in some sense
because it doesn't signify the
acquisition of it's not satiating it's
repetitive that's right and so it drives
you forward and you might think that
being driven forward would be unpleasant
but if you're in some sense if you're
activating the systems that drive you
forward voluntarily then that's the most
positive form of positive reinforcement
you can have
I think I I read animal researchers who
said that when they when they watched
animals who were bar pressing
to receive stimulation in those brain
areas the animals would look forward as
if something was about to appear that
they wanted to have a pier incredible so
that was part of that apprehension part
of it says it's a hope system in some
sense it's the elicitation of hope
that's right you know it's um dopamine
uh and here I'm robbing words from
others um like my colleague Anna Lemke
who you know it's not about having it's
about wanting it's not about pleasure as
much as it is about craving and
motivation and drive and something
critical about the banks have called it
seeking
yeah brilliant brilliant I never met
pankcept did you I did you ever you met
yuck I I met him I met him online we we
were in a we were in a neurological chat
room so to speak for a
neuropsychological chat room for about
five years and I had a chance to
interact with him a fair bit in that so
that was really good envious he just
he's done beautiful work and thank you
for calling people's attention to his
work I know you've done that many times
in such a key work
um the dopamine system is in touch with
the autonomic system sure because
um it has to register success versus uh
failure of some Pursuit that prefrontal
cortex is actually part of the dopamine
reward system people often overlook this
and we just think about nucleus
accumbens and ventral teg mental area
but the prefrontal cortex because as you
pointed out before it is generating
possible outcomes different rules
different selves are being projected
into the future
you can think that the two marshmallow
tasks the classic you know give kids uh
the option to either have a marshmallow
now or wait and have two marshmallows
and the cute little videos of the kids
you know in the room with the
marshmallows sniffing it talking to it
occasionally a kid will just stuff it in
his mouth another child will turn away
you know delightful right
um and all sorts of ideas have come
about about how they do in life versus
if they can wait or not wait in any case
that's dopaminergic anticipation the key
thing with dopamine I think that
encapsulates the most of it is this
notion of reward prediction error which
is very simple if you are excited and
anticipating something you are
generating some internal sense of the
probability of it happening we're going
to the ice cream store kids let's go
we're gonna have ice cream we have ice
cream
it's closed the disappointment
that they experience actually brings
them far lower than they would feel much
more sad than they would feel than had
you not told them you were going to get
ice cream which which speaks exactly to
what you were saying that it's an
anticipation signal so dopamine's going
up up we're going to get ice cream and
then no so it drops below Baseline they
would have been better off being not
told they were going to the ice cream
store just drive right by way the danger
of Hope danger of Hope if you anticipate
that it's going to be open and again
this could translate to any scenario and
it's open there's a dopaminergic signal
upon receiving the reward but it then
drops a little bit this is the basis of
addiction actually drops a little bit
below Baseline transiently so we always
think of the ice cream is the reward
well actually the reward was right
before you had that first lick of ice
cream because you know you're gonna get
it this is also true of sexual behavior
it's true of of um people who sell a
company or they're anticipating
something exciting or of a wedding it's
that it's this whole it also sort of
part partially explains this notion of
postpartum depression where people are
so excited about something the delivery
of a child or something in the arrival
and then for some reason they feel let
down it's because the anticipation was
that great
um so many many scenarios it might be an
exhaustion component there too well it's
also the case if I remember correctly
that that dopamine kick
so imagine what it does is back track
the neural systems that were activated
as the reward was approached
so then it feeds back reinforcement not
reward but but mediate cellular growth
and maybe maybe
myelinization it's increasing the
efficiency of the neural connections of
the systems that were activated just
prior to receiving that reward in the
order they were prioritized in the order
they were manifested so the closer the
behavior is to the receipt of the reward
the more it's reinforced and more likely
to be manifested in the future and then
there's a Decay function going back in
time
and so and that's partly how an
addictive
sub personality can grow too right
because you can imagine that there's a
certain state of mind that you're in
maybe it's a state of something
approximating nihilistic hopelessness
that grips you every time you're
motivated to seek out your favorite drug
and that's fairly far back in the
activation chain but it's there every
time you take a hit so what happens is
the dopaminergic reinforcement produced
by the drug reinforces that nihilistic
hopelessness that drives the
drug-seeking behavior and that's how in
part you develop a monkey on your back
yeah I I love the example even though I
I am sad that it happens for people I I
love the example because what you're
saying is that and it's exactly right
that the memory for events and states of
mind and emotions that preceded a
successful collection of reward or a
rival at reward is set into a huge
number of motor commands some of which
are subconscious and and right and the
the ultimate dopamine signal
actually I experienced this the other
day I can give an example
um my girlfriend and I decided to go to
the beach we were gonna go do this
little ritual that we've been talking
about doing for a while and I had on a
piece of paper what we had written out
we were going to do and I had in my back
pocket and we got to the ocean and the
sun was setting sort of perfect timing
for this and the piece of paper was gone
and I thought oh my goodness how did I
screw this up like of all the things you
know I'm supposed to you know I've been
I'm 47 years old this is I should be
able to to do this you know that I blew
it yeah I blew it so I went back to the
car Long Walk looking everywhere it was
not a windy day but I thought gosh
where's this piece of paper looking
around didn't find it all the way back
to the car wasn't the car came all the
way back and I was walking toward her I
saw her and I thought okay this is
really embarrassing I'm gonna just have
to have to wing it or remember we didn't
have our phones intentionally either so
we couldn't look it up and then I saw
the piece of paper on the beach and it
was partially buried in the sand I
picked it up and I was elated what
happened there was my dopamine had
dropped way below Baseline because I was
disappointed that I'd lost it
disappointed in myself Etc and then I
found it right and so your anticipation
was for nothing exactly so you got
punished by yourself for that exactly
because that should be eradicated if
you're highly anticipatory and it
doesn't make itself manifest then you
were seriously wrong so you're going to
take a emotional hit as a consequence of
that I think that's also Associated that
emotional hit that pain that you feel I
think that's actually associated with
the beginning stages of the death of the
systems that mediated that initial
response because you should eradicate
systems that make you anticipate that
don't work right and that means those
systems which are already instantiated
and alive in some sense have to Decay
and die and it strikes me as highly
probable that you're going to pay a
price in something approximating pain
for the death of those malfunctioning
systems that's also why because why
wouldn't they fight for their lives to
some degree why wouldn't they resist the
Decay and death that might be necessary
to keep you going why there should be
some pain associated with that logically
because it is a biological
transformation yeah it's an interesting
way to lends to view it through that
that self uh image that I had in that
moment of you know I'm a responsible
partner who can take care of a simple
thing right for this nice little ritual
that we've been talking about doing for
a while I failed right so that part
watch well it's also so interesting you
think about that this is a depressive
Cascade eh that and it's very hard to
bind because imagine you anticipate
something and then you make a mistake
now the question then becomes how
significant is the mistake and one view
of your error would be well the paper
blew out of my pocket and that could
happen to anybody
and the the more catastrophic
interpretation would be and it's an
extension of the thought path that you
started to walk down well I'm near 50
years old I should be much more
responsible than this and there's
something wrong with me as a person and
then a depressive person would go even
further they'd say well not only is
there something wrong with me in this
decision this is a decision like every
other decision I make right now I never
make a good decision in the past I've
never made a good decision and there's
no way I'm going to change in the future
and so they the depressive takes that
um punishment response let's say that's
a consequence of failed anticipation and
can't bind it it just it just takes out
all of their potential future selves
that's a good way of thinking about it
yeah and so then they're in a depressive
pit yeah it's so that's that's too much
learning from failure right that's a
it's a uh I'm really um I'm grateful for
it for your Insight on this because
indeed if I'm if I'm honest that my
thought train went to the point of um
you know I didn't think oh I'm a total
failure because I lost this piece of
paper I thought to myself well you know
if it were a priority I would have
ensured I wouldn't have lost it right
right show interpreter is not being a
priority like where are my priorities am
I you know am I overspent you know like
what what's going on you start to sift
into the the full set of questions and
then of course finding the paper
resurrects the sense of self it was you
know I think it was in that movie Pulp
Fiction yeah well that that binding
problem is really tricky eh because so
there's some good rules of thumb for
that which is it one of the rules of
thumb for that that's extremely useful
that's socially instantiated is innocent
until proven guilty
right so you might say when those
thoughts come up because they're
adversarial and accusatory thoughts you
might say well that is part of the realm
of possibility but I shouldn't when your
child does something wrong that's minor
you don't say you're a rotten kid
right you say
you bind it you say look kid here's a
bunch of things you're doing right
but in this particular example specific
situation here's the minimal thing you
did incorrectly and how to alter it and
it's a really good habit of mind it's
like to to address towards yourself as
well as to other people which is to say
well what's what's the minimum crime
that I am responsible for In This Moment
and that's part of this miracle of the
presumption of innocence and especially
without proof a lot of what I did in my
clinical practice to people who had a
depressive temperament was help them
make a case for themselves it's like
well maybe you're as bad as you think
you might be but maybe not let's take
the contrary argument let's make you as
innocent as you can be in this situation
and and only narrow the repair to the
absolute minimum that needs to be
manifested now
some people don't have that problem
because they don't have a depressive
state of mind let's say they're somewhat
resilient to the cascading effects of
punishment those are people who are low
in trait neuroticism by the way so you
could think of trait neuroticism as an
index to which the degree failure
co-activates punishment across a whole
sequence of
nested selves the more the higher you
are in neuroticism the more likely a
given error is to a Cascade up the
hierarchy of
possible cells and it's a it's a
trade-off because sometimes when you
make one little mistake it is actually
an indicator of a flaw in your character
but most of the time it isn't and it
certainly can't be responded to that all
the time because then you'd never be
able to make a mistake without wiping
yourself completely out and that's
obviously not helpful is it fair to say
that um at least in the the raising of
children and maybe in the raising of
ourselves that we should as much as
possible try and emphasize that errors
are due to State not trait
um you know yes absolutely and you do
that in an argument with your with your
your wife as well you you want to make
it you want to make it as local and
precise as you possibly can so and
that's also one of the advantages to
removing yourself from a rage or an
anxiety state because a rage or an
anxiety state is low resolution and
Global and so it'll be globally
accusatory
and and so you want to specify and think
okay well what's the what's the minimum
necessary behavioral transformation to
ensure that similar mistakes are not
replicated in the future and generally
that doesn't require like read it's like
if your roof leaks you don't have to dig
a New Foundation you can just fix a few
shingles and you might think well the
rain's coming through so you have to
tear down the whole house it's like well
no you have to and you might panic and
run around because the water's coming in
but it's still a bad idea to dig up the
foundations every time something trivial
maintenance problem needs to emerge and
so one of the things that's very useful
to learn is like well is this only a
trivial maintenance problem and one of
the advantages to that too is that if
it's not the collapse of your entire
self let's say and it's a trivial
maintenance problem you're much more
able to activate that that courageous
response to anomaly that's part and
parcel of exploratory behavior and
eventually success
so and part of the trick of of many
sorts of of well I would say religious
training Enterprises certainly the
meditative Enterprises is something like
how do you tell yourself a story like a
real story though a story that actually
works that's most likely to put yourself
put yourself in a position where you can
confidently approach the thing that's
blocking your path
this um this notion uh you brought up
three points that I I think immediately
of the the related neurology but I'm
going to repeat them back to make sure I
understand because they're very Salient
in my mind right now which is this
notion of the prefrontal cortex trying
different versions of self and working
with uh contending with bodily States in
that in those moments
um and the sort of either death or or uh
you know you know or or growth or
resurrection of those different selves
depending on the outcomes right right
the next I I this notion of state or
trade I find uh fascinating you know
after I found that piece of paper I felt
like I was like the greatest you know I
got this huge dopamine surge because
it's it's the Delta it's the difference
between your Baseline and the people
yeah right so even though I lost it
right I mean I should have thought oh
gosh I wasted 30 minutes of our time but
instead I thought I found I found this
amazing and I felt so elated I think
there was a it was the movie Pulp
Fiction I think it was the John Travolta
character said something I'm gonna get
this wrong but you know he said it was
almost worth losing that just to find it
again he was talking about something I
forget what it was right and I think
that captured it there as well and then
my question is however is you know we've
been talking about if you lose something
or if an outcome was not great how that
can fan out into and kind of over
interpretation of trait and and this
kind of depressive neurotic uh
interpretation what about the opposite
where certainly for every success that
one has you know um like for instance if
I had had not dropped this piece of
paper I wouldn't have thought of it as a
great success I would have just thought
of it as what I was required to do in
that moment right it was sort of just
Beauty right um and I'm not somebody who
um celebrates with everything I check
off my list I you know sometimes yes
they're bigger uh bigger things than
others bigger achievements than others
but I can imagine that certain people
might over inflate their wins
um Mannix manix over inflate there it is
they're bad so while dopamine system
yeah well for a manic every every
possible self is wonderful
simultaneously
and so they're completely fragmented
right because every possibility is 100
dopaminergically giving him a
dopaminergic kick and so it's complete
it's complete positive emotion
catastrophe on the manic side
so these systems they have to exist in
such tight balance right because all of
your potential positive selves are not
to be regarded with exceptional
enthusiasm that's a form of pathology
even though like people don't like being
treated for Mania often because
especially going into a manic state is
very enjoyable
because it is associated with enthusiasm
and that's all dopamine dopamine
mediated positive emotion but
the pr there are problems with positive
emotion and one is well it needs to be
uh judicious and
um differentiated you shouldn't be
positive about everything which is why
you shouldn't reward children
indiscriminately it has to be targeted
and so when a system loses its focus and
Target its capacity to discriminate then
it becomes pathological and people don't
often think of pathologies of positive
emotion but Mania is definitely that's
definitely what it is and it makes
people impulsive too
and fragmented even in their speech
someone who's really manic is a
different person every sentence
that's it's interesting because one
thing that we know again about the
dopamine system it's about anticipation
the the other the other thing that is
absolutely clear about the dopamine
system
is that it is tact to Pursuit more than
it is to outcomes but it is highly
subjective to to interpretation and this
is exciting actually and holds great
possibility I mean putting Mania aside
you know when we are when dopamine is
elevated it tends to put our perception
to things outside of our I would say
beyond the confines of our skin that
person you know that potential lover
that food that reward that thing it's
about Target it's all about that Target
and I think this explains why yeah why
manics are all about plans in the future
I'm going to do this and I'm going to be
president and I'm going to do that and
Etc
um
yeah you see the opposite of neuroticism
because one of the one of the phenomenon
cognitive phenomena that loads very
heavily on neuroticism is
self-consciousness
and so when you fall into anxiety Then
There is this internal obsessiveness
which has to do with your pet the
panoply of sins in some sense which
parts of me are malfunctioning and need
to be eradicated and one of the things I
used to do with my socially anxious
clients so they would go into a social
situation often with eyes downcast by
the way and they would be so intensely
concentrating on their own internal
Sensations
that they would fail to make eye contact
with anybody they were talking to and
then they would be awkward because they
weren't reading the cues they could have
read if they would have only looked and
then the conversation would become
disjointed and then they would get
anxious and fall into themselves and
then it would just spiral I see and so
one of the things that I taught them to
do wasn't to try to calm themselves down
but to try to calm the other person down
so when you go into a social situation
pay more attention to the other person
like just focus your attention outward
and if the person had any social skill
sometimes I had clients who had no shows
or skills and so they were anxious
socially because they actually didn't
know how to behave socially so then you
had to teach them the social skills but
some of them had the skills but wouldn't
activate them because they were so
neurotically obsessed with their own
inadequacy that they failed to attend to
the cues that would elicit the proper
responses and all they had to learn to
do was wash
and then they would automatically
respond because they knew how to have a
conversation that there there's a um
this brings us to some of the Practical
tools that I think my laboratory has
been working on which is you know many
people have heard about the utility of
mindfulness meditation which most
typically is close your eyes focus on
Third Eye Center or your breathing you
know bring your awareness to your
so-called interception you know
perception can be intercepted from the
skin inward or extra receptive to the
world outward the data are showing that
people who are overly uh socially
anxious for instance
um they are too in much in touch with
their bodily signals in fact they can
Count Their Own they can Count Their Own
heartbeats without taking their pulse
with their finger which is a high end
which is a great indicator of how
interreceptively aware you are those
people would probably be best to avoid
inward folking focusing excuse me
meditations well well it's hard to say
because there may be a variable there
that's relevant
see the reason that socially anxious
people are so interceptive is it's
involuntary right right they get gripped
by the negative emotion and then that
produces this intense obsessive
interoception
that might not happen if they did it
voluntarily I see because right because
you're going to activate an entire
different system the one you already
talked about this is why exposure
therapy works so well in in
Psychotherapy is like well I'm afraid of
something and if I go near it then I'm
possessed by negative emotion well
that's if you go near it accidentally
I'm going to have you go near it
purposefully and what you're going to
find is that to the degree that you do
it purposefully that response will be
quelled and that happens it's
extraordinarily reliable and it does
seem to be this is why I was wondering
about gene expression so imagine that
you have someone who's habitually
avoidant and maybe they're avoidant
because when they become possessed by
negative emotion they become hyper aware
of their internal State and they feel
the panic and so then they freeze or
retreat and they do that constantly and
so and then and then they're in this
terrible negative emotional state all
the time because every time they see a
stimulus that's associated with retreat
they get gripped by these interceptive
uh um Sensations
and so you say to them well we're going
to reverse that instead of you being
gripped by that
by Fiat by the command of these
underlying systems you're going to
expose yourself to that voluntarily now
you could imagine that what you're doing
is in imposing the dominance of that
nucleus reunions on the anxiety
provoking systems and so I'm wondering
see if you do that repeatedly with
people
not only do they stop being afraid of
the things that you're
that you're showing them that you're
exposing it to but they become more
likely to approach other things they're
afraid of far more likely in fact it
doesn't exactly look like people get
more less afraid at all it looks like
what happens is they learn to get braver
and that generalizes and so I was
wondering when I was reading your
research today is it the case that if
you put someone in chronically and
voluntarily into a state where let's say
the nucleus reunions is activated that
that transforms their character at the
genetic level so that that's more likely
to be the case in the future so really
retools them all the way down to the DNA
um incredibly important question it's
the question again uh you're asking the
the exact questions that we're pursuing
now and here's the answer uh there are
two modes of changing these responses in
the neural circuitry one lies in
so-called neuroplasticity which is the
could be strengthening of synapses or
just reordering of nerve connections
could be the addition of memory cells
there's a lot of excitement about the
addition of new neurons but really that
only reflects a small percentage of
changes in the brain of adults it's
actually more the rewiring of existing
connections but the mechanism doesn't
matter so much something gets rewired
such that the response is then different
going forward and indeed that happens
any system that Taps into the dopamine
system and indeed what we're talking
everything we're talking about today
does
is highly subject to reward induced
neuroplasticity yeah in fact so much so
that some of the best experiments done
on this have shown that if you give
somebody a a drug that transiently
increases dopamine works better if you
also transiently increase acetylcholine
or something like that as well but for
the next hours you know one to four
hours the of the neuroplasticity is
scaled up right it takes many fewer
trials or many fewer
um cognitive behavioral therapy sessions
this has only been done a few times or
many fewer learning sessions to create a
permanent shift in the neurology such
that okay so does okay so does
are at the outset of a task that you're
doing something important so you're
approaching a valued goal and you're in
you have a lot of anticipation as a
consequence of that does that mean that
you put yourself in a neural chemical
state that facilitates learning
absolutely without question so if you
believe what you're doing is important
if you truly believe that because it's
related to an important goal and it's a
pathway Way Forward then that's going to
transform into a manifestation of
neuroplasticity absolutely and every
time I hear about the sort of you know
woo statements about
um you know uh you know I don't want to
offend anyone here but sure I'll just
say you know you hear about the secret
or manifesting or intention all of that
is really yeah it's capturing a
fundamental principle of the way that
our neurology Works which is that the
prefrontal cortex as a rule setting but
flexible rule setting machine that Taps
into the dopamine system can absolutely
adopt new rules for reward release in
the brain again there's basically only
one reward system there's also serotonin
system as you know but the dopamine
system is the major currency of reward
so much so that for instance
everyone knows that food is rewarding we
anticipate food we eat a delicious steak
uh or something and we feel rewarded
however if you are somebody who can
attach thought such as fasting is good
for me I'm going to do intermittent
fasting where I'm not going to eat those
foods and therefore I'm going to attach
my thinking to the rewards that will
come with Better Health better
Aesthetics Etc yeah the dopamine system
responds it's not just a belief in a
narrative it's a it's a real response
and what actually starts to happen is
that people start to enjoy the foods
that they in that they are restricting
themselves to more they're actually
beautiful data on this from my colleague
Ali crumbs laboratory at Stanford that
if you believe a food is nutritious and
good for you it actually has better
impact on your physiology of course
there are the rules of physiology and
nutrition that still apply right you
can't tell yourself that the garbage is
good for us right but but there's a
significant scaling up of the positive
response that's associated with dopamine
and hormonal Cascades which we can talk
about in a moment in the same way if one
adopts a sort of a Carol dewekian growth
mindset approach okay it's not about
receiving the reward that the more the
more strain I feel the more effort that
I'm putting in the closer I'm getting to
my goal that over time will become a
rewarding State such that one will
pursue states of Reason yeah well it
should it should be also it should be
also proportional to the magnitude of
the goal that's right right and so so
this is I think why people are so
obsessed in some sense with the search
for fundamental meaning it's because you
want to be able to associate so imagine
I this is a good story so you can
imagine two people laying bricks they're
building a gigantic wall and the one
person thinks oh my God you know this
wall is going to take a hundred thousand
bricks and I'm laying one at a time and
I'm wasting my life away
trivially adding to this
gigantic brick wall and what am I doing
this is absolutely miserable Brick by
Brick and the other person thinks uh in
300 years this is going to be a
cathedral
and so the person in the second state is
doing exactly the same thing at a local
level Lane bricks but each brick is
related to a very high goal and that
means the reward that's attendant upon
the laying of the brick is proportional
to the goal to the what to the aim of
the of the entire behavioral process and
so it seems to me so if you're aimless
and goalless and I know you've done some
work on goal setting if you're aimless
and goals goalless then you can't elicit
any positive emotion and if your goals
are fragmented which is also what
happens if you're aimless or your goals
lack Unity if your goals are fragmented
then no given behavioral manifestation
can elicit any dopaminergic reward
because it's not a step forward to
anything desirable and so there's no
positive emotion
and so you can't learn well according to
your according to your account I didn't
know that see I didn't know that when
you put yourself in a state of
apprehension in relationship to a valued
goal that your neuroplasticity improves
and you can learn better that's very
very cool so because I you know I just
developed this app for writing called
essay and one of the things we do
is we tell people we tell people that
when they sit down to write an essay
that's the first the most important
thing you have to do is you have to have
a question in mind
that you regard finding the answer to as
worthwhile
otherwise the whole exercise is a lie
so even if you're assigned a topic you
have to find something within the topic
that grips you
and provides you with the motivation
that's appropriate to move forward with
the essay with the attempt
and it is a lie otherwise are you
wasting your words you're you're you're
engaging in futile activity and you're
going to write something dull and
terrible and it's going to frustrate you
and bore you while you're doing it and
that's because your own nervous system
is telling you that you're participating
in something that you have no belief in
and so but if you do if you're gripped
by the questions like God I really want
to answer this question it's like well
you're in a perfect condition to begin
to write an intelligible essay because
you actually want the answer and then
the writing exercise is going to be
gripping because you're grappling with a
real mystery and that and that's so cool
if if doing that also puts you in a
state where you're much more likely to
learn
which makes sense right because if
you're doing something important and you
seem to be moving forward that's a
really good time to learn
neurophysiologically that would make or
evolutionarily that would make perfect
sense absolutely you know the system of
the dopaminergic system that we're
talking about anticipation and then
action and reward or in some cases no
reward right and the the ability to
persist toward a goal regardless is a
generalizable system uh you know you had
that chapter about you know get your
room in order right get your belongings
in order this is I think very relevant
right now even though it's important to
have higher goals and lofty goals the
dopamine system is an incredible system
because it is it is depletable and yet
it's also renewable and it is
self-amplifying what I mean by that is
let's say that I'm somebody who doesn't
know what I'm working toward I don't
have a specific goal or question
by completing even what seemed like
menial tasks like making myself a cup of
coffee drinking it cleaning up
completely drying the cup and putting it
back in the cupboard what happens is if
even if you make that seemingly trivial
goal the goal in addition to making the
kitchen look nicer it completes a
circuit it closes the dopaminergic
circuit and when dopamine is released
and it will be maybe not to the same
extent as publishing a novel but to some
extent dopamine amplifies our ability to
think into the future to make additional
plans that are unrelated to what you
just did and it literally increases
confidence and energy why well for the
following reason we all think about
caloric energy but what most people are
never taught you know and if I had 10
things I could teach people one of them
would be
adrenaline epinephrine is neural energy
it's your ability to get up and go it's
the thing that makes you jittery when
you're a little nervous but it's also it
allows you to move forward to go out for
a run to pursue any goal cognitive or
physical Etc
epinephrine which is also adrenaline
those are the same thing is literally
manufactured from the molecule dopamine
if you look at the biochemical Cascade
it is dopamine is converted into
adrenaline which is the basis of all
energy all neural energy right and so
including thinking and so if one is not
in a place of being able to set their
goal on a particular lofty goal a
graduate degree a book Etc yet the way
one gets to that is by completing things
in their immediate environment from
start to finish and closing the
dopaminergic loop you literally yeah
well those are at least those are at
least micro narrative that's right right
so they're not integrated across a long
span of time but they're not nothing and
so one of the things well I did write
about this in my first book particularly
about putting your life putting your
house in perfect order it's like well if
you if you're lost
one of the things you can do is look
around and see what direction you could
take locally is fix something and I used
to tell my clients this is a very good
thing to know
find something that you could do
that would make things better that you
would do
and there's a humility in that too
because especially if you're in a low
energy State it's like oh my God you
know I don't have enough energy to make
dinner it's like do you have enough
energy to put a fork on the table and
sometimes people are so depressed that
that's really all they can do it's like
can you take can you take a small step
forward no matter how small that is and
so that's I didn't see I knew that
adrenaline was
a byproduct or a a
down the biochemical chain from dopamine
but I didn't get the significance of
that fully so basically what you're
saying is that if you implement a micro
routine even something like washing a
cup and putting it back in the shelf and
you know that's a good thing because you
have a shelf and there's cups on it
you've already decided that's an
appropriate way to live is to have your
coffee cups on the Shelf if you go ahead
with cleaning out the cup and putting it
on the Shelf then you've taken steps
towards a valuable micro goal you get a
dopamine kick from that that transforms
itself into adrenaline and energizes you
which then that's partly the reason that
it has an antidepressant effect that's
right and then you can lean into another
Behavior I mean some of the the more
successful classes of antidepressants
again not for everybody are the ones of
the dopaminergic adrenal energy uh
variety right things like prior own as
opposed to you know there's a lot of
debate about ssris they tap into a
different system you asked about gene
expression changes
um the there's neuroplasticity which is
on the short scale completion of an even
trivial task like the putting away of
the cup will give you more dopamine
which gives you more adrenaline which in
this analogy of either being back on
one's heels flat-footed or forward
Center of mass regardless of where one
is starting out let's say depressed is
back on one's heels it's going to tilt
you forward a little bit and that's a
question of what you think of what you
do with it so the cognitive appraisal is
critical because again with the
prefrontal cortex being so critical in
establishing which of these Loops gets
repeated the cognitive appraisal is
critical I'm somebody who can get things
done even if they're small now if you do
the cognitive appraisal or or you can
you can take another cognitive appraisal
there too which is
it's small things are not small
that's right
precisely for the reason that we just
described it's like you might have the
cognitive appraisal that doing something
local like cleaning up your room is
small but it's not obvious at all that
that's the case it's not
it's not that trivial to put your
immediate surroundings in order and it
can easily be the stepping stone to
putting things in order on a broader
scale in fact it's probably the
necessary stepping stone to do that and
so they might seem small but there are
they're a step ahead and the head is a
good direction absolutely and so they're
not as small as you might think and so
you can pat yourself on the back
especially if you're depressed a little
harder than you might otherwise by
saying you know you say well this is
Trivial but I did it it's like no
if you're moving ahead tilting yourself
forward in your in your metaphor that's
not small you just keep doing that
you're going to get out of this
paralyzed or Retreat mode and then God
only knows what you're going to be able
to do that's right and I think that if
people were to look at these
neurological and psychological processes
because we're really talking about both
is as algorithms right these are these
are algorithms that have been used by
every animal think about the animal
that's foraging for food they go down
One path they're surprised they find
food they go down another path they're
sure they're on Ascent they are sure and
then they get nothing well what happens
they learn
to remember they and automatically
remember everything that led to that
failure and people are very good at
remembering that but be good at
remembering the things that led to
successes and then ride those
neurochemical waves to the next node of
exploration you're talking about
exploration versus anxiety you can also
do this with people in your environment
you know this is something BF Skinner
pointed out when he was training animals
said you can use threat and Punishment
to train animals but he said the most
effective mode of training isn't that at
all you use sustained attention and
reward and so imagine that you're
training a route to climb up a Ladder
rung by rung and then do a little dance
on the top and then climb down the other
side so what Skinner would do his
animals were hungry by the way they were
starved to 75 percent of their body
weight so they were pretty
dopaminergically motivated by the
provision of any food he would watch
them wander around in the cage where a
ladder was let's say a little uh rap
Monkey Bar apparatus and then when the
rat would get near the last matter he
give the food pellet so then it was soon
spending a lot of time near the ladder
and now and then while it was monkeying
about it would put one foot on the one
paw on the first rung it was like food
pellet and then it would soon be doing
that and then sooner later would put the
next paw on and he'd reward it and so
Skinner Skinner trained pigeons to
um pilot
guided missiles by pecking on photos in
relationship to the ground they were
watching right so spectacular you could
use reward in a number so one of the
things you can do in your local
environment and with yourself as well is
you can watch people around you and you
can see when they make small steps
towards manifesting some behaviors you'd
like to see a lot more of and then you
can tell them in this very
differentiated discriminatory manner you
can say Hey look
here's the sequence of actions you just
undertook I saw that I noted the process
and here's the delightful outcome good
work and man if you do that repeatedly
to people around you and you don't want
to do this in a fake or manipulative way
but if you're attentive to what people
are doing that's good and you mark that
with a reward man you produce behavioral
Transformations at a rate that's just
beyond belief I love it and everyone
feels great about it too yeah it's
really a good habit man it's giving
credit we're not separating the wheat
from the chaff in the truest sense to
give credit where credit is due yeah the
behavior and you can imagine you're
facilitating growth in the manner that
you just described and maybe what
neurolog or genetic transformation we
didn't get to the gene expression part
yet yeah the the behaviorists like
Skinner were truly brilliant and and I
think one experiment that I think is
worth mentioning which is um kind of
speaks to the power of dopamine and why
it's so vital to tap into these systems
even through menial tasks then to build
on their self-amplifying mode so that
you can take on bigger things in life so
to speak
positive goals is there's a classic
experiment now that's been done in
humans and in animals where you take two
rats separate cages or you could do this
with humans where their naturalistic
conditions where one of the rats or
humans actually has their dopamine
depleted
um in humans this happens through
parkinsonian things or the ingestion of
drugs which accidentally deplete the
dopaminergic neurons and what you find
is that if you give them an opportunity
to experience something pleasureful like
hit a hit a lever and get a pellet of
food
or people to access some very tasty food
um both people with dopamine and with
very depleted dopamine animals with
dopamine or without dopamine will eat
the food they will pursue the food but
only if it's right in front of them if
you put any kind of task between a
person or an animal and a reward what
you find is that a rat won't move one
rat's life
to press a lever to get the food so they
are able to experience pleasure but what
they are unable to do is to embark on
any kind of effort to achieve that
pleasure right so that's so oh that's so
cool so that means that in part what the
dopamine system is doing so imagine that
the purpose of the dopamine system is to
elicit a satiating reward that's right
fundamentally but then necessiating
reward is something that has to be
approached in in steps that's right and
so in order to maintain the motivation
necessary to approach the satiating
reward you have to mark each of the
steps with a with a marker of pleasure
and so the dopamine system is marking
the intermediary steps and then it's
it's doing that to overcome the
reluctance that you'd have to expend the
energy in that micro routine that would
otherwise be costly by calculating the
fact that there's a net reward that's
nested in the ultimate satiation that's
right and parsing that out across the
yeah yeah and sometimes people will
experience tremendous anxiety in pursuit
of their rewards you know the social
situation or the the goal or the book
you know people imagine failure like
crazy as as I'm sure you know we've all
heard and seen what's critical again is
this cognitive appraisal this
interpretation of that if you think of
that anxiety as a natural system of
getting you to move of just biasing your
body toward movement toward action as
opposed to inaction because that's what
anxiety really is it's a bias toward
action then you can literally reshape
the whole notion of what it feels like
to have elevated heart rate maybe
Trembling Hands maybe flushing in the
face when one is doing public speaking
you do it enough times you get pretty
comfortable
now there are situations in life I
should just mention such as sleep
deprivation or uh in particular that
tend to make this whole set of systems
with prefrontal cortex and limbic stuff
and ACC and insula kind of disregulated
it makes it harder to manage that goes
without saying right you know the
quickest way to peel somebody apart is
to sleep deprive them for two or three
nights one night you're probably fine
right right so you know all the basics
of self-care of good nutrition social
connections sleep uh exercise sunlight
those still apply I just want to mention
that I I want to make sure I answer your
question about gene expression and
permanent changes
um because I've failed to do that thus
far one of the things that is absolutely
key about the dopamine system is that it
has a fast component dopamine is
released more adrenaline AKA epinephrine
can be released and you can re you know
this sort of upward spiral of energy and
and sort of success with the occasional
drops right I mean nobody succeeds in
every task right sometimes the phone
rings or the doorbell rings and you fail
you know uh goodness you fail to clean
the cup you come home like are you going
to crash into a puddle of Tears no you
just clean it then and then put it away
right
um of course but there's a slow system
associated with achieving wins even
small wins and that slow system is in
the form of hormonal control that then
translates to Gene control so two
hormones in particular testosterone and
estrogen which are present in both men
and women males and females of course
um but to varying degrees
um are both
secreted when the dopamine system is
activated this has to do with the
relationship between dopaminergic
neurons and the pituitary gland which
releases gonadotropins and luteinizing
hormones which then stimulate the testes
and the ovaries Etc to release the
so-called sex steroid hormones the sex
steroid hormones testosterone and
estrogen of course are involved in
reproductive biology but they are both
vitally important provided there in the
proper ratios for motivational biology
and for the following reason the steroid
hormones are are so-called lipophilic
and they can cross from the outside of a
cell through the cell membrane to
actually into the nucleus of a cell and
control gene expression so when we
achieve winds repeatedly and again this
doesn't matter if you're male or female
you achieve wins it repeatedly
testosterone is the molecule that
eventually accesses not just cells to
control their immediate physiology but
goes into the nucleus of those cells and
controls their gene expression and what
it translate so so does that mean okay
so does that mean that demotivated men
are producing less testosterone uh we
can say that that the data show that
repeated failures
take testosterone levels lower than they
would be otherwise that is not to say
that people with low testosterone will
always fail those with higher testosters
but just to be clear because I don't
know you are correct but just people
sometimes get hitched on this causal
part but indeed one of the quickest ways
to boost someone's testosterone is to
have them achieve a win of some sort now
the win is translated well one of the
things you do one of the things you do
in behavior therapy constantly is you
help people calibrate the zone of
proximal development
so imagine that that's the godsky's term
right and so if you're in the zone of
proximal development you're pushing your
skill development one increment forward
and it's one that you can actually
manage and so if you see people who are
entirely stymied we're sort of back to
the cup of coffee or the coffee cup
example you want to find something they
can do locally this week that would
constitute at least a micro wind and you
just keep and if if you talk to someone
you say well
why don't you try cleaning up your room
because it's a complete catastrophic
nightmare it's a good place to start
this is often the case with people who
are really demoralized and whose life is
utterly chaotic and maybe they come back
later and say well you know like I had
one client he uh he just had a child eh
and he didn't want to mess up this child
but he was living at home he was like 35
years old he had a child out of wedlock
by accident but he didn't want to be a
useless father and he was very afraid he
was going to be and he had good reason
to like he still lived at home he lived
in his high school bedroom and it was a
complete bloody mess he was living like
a 12 year old you know a bad 12 year old
and so I said well when was the last
time that your carpet was vacuumed and
he said well sometimes my mother does it
but it's probably been months I said why
don't you just bring the vacuum cleaner
into the room and uh just vacuum your
carpet that'll be your task for this
week you know and I knew that was a
bigger task than you might think because
he'd been in that room for like 18 years
and it was a mess and so cleaning it up
at all was a big deal he told me that
he dragged that Bloody vacuum cleaner
into the doorway and left it 45 degrees
across the doorway and then stepped over
it for the whole week without actually
using my goodness yeah resistance say
from that was resistance from a
psychoanalytic perspective because he he
saw the monster and was paralyzed and so
what we did was we reduced the task I
said look you've got some drawers in
your in your Bureau they're probably a
mess do you have a sock drawer yes it
says like clean up one half of the sock
drawer this week
that's it just organize it
so you just keep cutting the tasks down
week by week until you find the
threshold for positive movement forward
and then it's what's cool about that too
is there's a Pareto Principle issue
associated with it so if you can find
out where the person can start
it isn't linear progress It's
exponential progress forward and so even
if they have to start at a micro level
it doesn't really matter because they
get much better at it very very rapidly
as they accrue successes
maybe that's because they're learning in
the way that you described okay so back
to the gene regulation it increases
testosterone the winds and yeah so
testosterones are associated winds do
winners tend to be able to win more
there's some um Etc but you know if we
want to bring this into the the common
world you know a few years back when I
started doing some public-facing
education
I started getting a lot of questions
especially on YouTube from young males
um about
porn pornography and masturbation and
and this becomes very relevant here we
have to remember that this dopaminergic
system had is generalizable to many
different behaviors right academic
Pursuits uh Sports Pursuits relationship
Pursuits but fundamentally it was again
I wasn't a consulted the design phase
but fundamentally it's tacked into the
the Adaptive survival behaviors in every
species including ours has at least two
major
um motivations which is uh to protect
its young and to make more of itself to
make more young at some level
people can opt out of that but one of
the the absolutely pathologic situations
for any animal or human is to be able to
access
repeated dopamine surges without effort
or any Pursuit that's self-directed and
or that's directed I should say so for
instance cocaine a drug which potently
increases dopamine or Methamphetamine
which potently increases methamphetamine
but doesn't require any sort of
um adaptive action Pursuit except to
acquire the drug and spend money on no
sacrifice No sacrifice so what
essentially what ends up happening is
the circuit that gets rewarded is only
the drug-seeking behavior and no other
Behavior will give the kind of potent
dopamine release that cocaine or
Methamphetamine will which is why they
are so pernicious now likewise I'm not
well plus plus they have that powerful
reinforcing effect right so not only do
you get that kick but what's reinforced
by the dopamine release is the behaviors
that were right prior particularly break
prior to the ingestion and if it all
that is is the drug taking Behavior
that's all that develops that's right
you build that monster inside your head
that's right so I can see where you're
going on the pornography right so I was
starting to get a lot of questions I was
kind of surprised I thought well you
know I'm male and you know maybe that's
why they feel comfortable ask me if you
were saying that we're asking about
pornography and they were asking you
know I I realize we want to um you know
I'll just be direct about they were
asking whether or not masturbation was
bad they were asking whether or not
masturbation with ejaculation was
particularly bad and here's my stance on
this I'm a biologist and a
neuroscientist not a psychologist but
what we know for sure is that if an
individual repeatedly engages in this
circuitry let's say masturbation and
pornography with increasingly
um potent forms of stimulation that are
on a screen a couple of things happen
first of all what's being reinforced
what's being reinforced is a high
dopaminergic response to watching other
people engage in sexual behavior which
is very different than being in a first
person sexual experience okay so right
there you know that what's being
reinforced is not actually any kind of
improvement in communication skills it's
voyeurism and and as these questions
started to come in more and more I
started to realize there was a lot of
kind of undertones of people talking
about fear of or experience with sexual
dysfunction that clearly pornography can
lead to and here I'm specifically
talking about males I I actually don't
know the literature on females so here
I'm talking about females don't use
visual pornography to the same degree
they use literary pornography I see so
yeah so and then you start to think
about okay what happens in the Cascade
or the Arc of of sexual arousal and and
orgasm what happens is that initially
there's a it's parasympathetically
dominant meaning if somebody is too uh
stressed they actually can't engage in
sexual behavior the arousal response
doesn't occur
erection is blunted but the actual
orgasm response and ejaculation is
strongly associated with the so-called
sympathetic nervous system which has
nothing to do with sympathy has
everything to do with it's a kind of a
stress response and then it reverses to
a parasympathetic response and that
hormone called prolactin increases drama
automatically after ejaculation in males
what does that do that blunts dopamine
release and testosterone for a very long
period of time which makes sense if pair
bonding and sort of you know in our
species anywhere there's this idea that
then other molecules would be exchanged
with Partners pair bonding potential for
raising mates Etc without getting into a
huge discussion about that the point is
this
masturbation and pornography are
potently tapping into the dopamine
system and can undermine the very
processes of which I consider healthy
processes of finding a mate you know
dating communication eventually if it's
appropriate sexual interaction Etc it's
undermining
oh so okay so here's a question if if
you're if you're seeking sexual release
through pornography and you go through
the whole cycle and you get a prolactin
release
do you bond with yourself so this is
very interesting the um it's the biology
explains it as what's left there is a
kind of an open loop a kind of an
emptiness right because bonding with the
self is a complicated notion I mean it
had there's a healthy version of that of
course loving oneself and yeah um and
self-referencing and again this is more
uh your Dome far more your domain than
mine in terms of how what a healthy
self-relation is but in the absence of
uh a real partner there of a absence of
real sexual partner there's an open loop
of neurochemicals including oxytocin and
prolactin the dopamine remember dopamine
goes up during Pursuit anticipation then
Peaks and then crashes below Baseline
after orgasm and ejaculation so this
kind of low that people fear is putting
them into an a-motivated State we can
think of this if I were to kind of
expand on it would be it's this it's
this kind of a neurochemical
psychological equivalent of making your
home environment filthy for a while not
actually putting you into this positive
amplification of dopamine so it depletes
the dopamine system and is likewise in
drugs of abuse and addiction it
eventually depletes the dopamine system
initially there's a huge dopamine surge
with drugs of abuse like methamphetamine
and cocaine but over time people are
using more and more to achieve what is
not such a great High you even see this
a little bit
with
um kind of consumption of energy drinks
like people are taking more and more
chemicals within their energy drinks and
they're thinking about loud fast music
energy drinks it's kind of stacking of
dopaminergic tools now that's not as
pathologic in fact I'm I'm there are
some energy drinks I'll occasionally
drink and I enjoy them
um I don't think we need to be entirely
afraid of pursuing or engaging in things
that release dopamine obviously healthy
sexual behavior food that we love social
engagement all of these things can be
dopaminergic it's the big peaks in
dopamine that are not associated with
any prior effort or organization of self
that are particularly dangerous for the
human being yeah well you could see that
that you could see that that that's a
cardinal danger of of uh affluence then
that's right this is why the children of
you know you know that's right you know
you cannot get rats addicted to cocaine
if they live in their natural
environments is that right
you can only get rats addicted to
cocaine if they're isolated rats in a
cage
yeah they won't bar press for cocaine in
the natural environment and it's because
they have alternative sources of
dopamine energy gratification very
interesting so yeah that's very
interesting yeah the children are very
wealthy people who are over indulged
I've seen that many times many many
times and it is a very sad sight
um yeah well they're not optimally
deprived eh and that that issue of
optimal deprivation that's that's a
killer issue for an affluent society
we're going to have to stop
because it's been more than an hour and
a half and I don't want to stop because
there were a bunch of things I wanted to
talk to you about I wanted to talk to
you about and I should let everybody
know who's listening if you go to Dr
huberman's podcast you can hear them
discuss some of these things we were
going to talk about dream sleep rest and
learning because we didn't talk about
the relationship between dreams and
learning and reinforcement which I'd
love to talk to you about we didn't talk
about fasting we didn't talk about
physical health aging it how to
ameliorate it we didn't talk about salt
we didn't talk about flexibility and we
didn't talk about gratitude so I would
say we should probably do another
podcast at some point I would also tell
everyone who's watching and listening
that Dr huberman invited me onto his
podcast and so some of these things we
can discuss when that happens because I
would like to have that happen to that I
would also like to yeah I'd be good it'd
be good we obviously have lots to talk
about I would also tell people I'm going
to do another half an hour with Dr
huberman on The Daily wire plus platform
I use that time to investigate a little
bit
um people's success stories I suppose I
think it's very useful for young people
in particular to get exposed to
individuals who've carved out success at
least in some domains of their life and
to find out what the story pathways are
let's say the autobiographical Pathways
that facilitate that kind of success
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com